depuis le milieu de l'année 1964 marcel
dassault avait fait discrètement étudié
par sa société sur fonds propres un
petit appareil bi sonic le mirage iii e
deux monoplaces destinés à l'exportation
il possède comme le mirage iii f2 une
voilure en flèche le réacteur est un
steak maatar neuf cas identique à celui
du mirage iv à marcel dassault lens à la
fin de l'année 65 avec l'apport de ces
coopérants industriels la fabrication
d'un prototype capable de convenir à
l'armée de l'air et qui prendra le nom
est sain
c'est en 1966 que volera pour la
première fois le mirage f1 sur
l'aérodrome de villaroche
le mirage f1 se caractérise par une
importante progression des performances
il peut voler à plus de mach 2 et
surtout se poser à seulement 125 de
grâce à une hyper sustentation très
poussée des ailes avec des becs d'attac
et des volets à double fente pourtant
très difficile à réaliser sur une
helmand
équipée d'un réacteur intérimaire snecma
attar 9k 31 le mirage f 1 01 effectué
son premier vol le 23 décembre 1966 à
melun villaroche piloté par rené bigand
le 7 janvier 1967 il atteint mc2d son
quatrième vol
les épaules se poursuivre quand le 18
mai 1967 au cours d'un vol à basse
altitude et à grande vitesse les
empannages horizontaux du mirage f 1 0 1
se détache à la suite d'un phénomène de
vibrations divergent ap les flottements
l'avion percute le sol près de fos sur
mer rené big en chef pilote de dassault
vient de se tuer malgré l'accident la
commande de trois avions de près syrie
mirage f1 0,2 0,3 et 0,4 à réacteurs à
tard neuf cas 50 et notifiée
le mirage f 1 02 doté d'un attar 9k 31
accompli son premier vol à istres le 20
mars 1969 piloté par jean marie saget et
atteint mach 1 15 le mirage f 1 0 3
équipé d'un moteur snecma 9 qu'à 50 vols
quant à lui le 18 septembre 1969 enfin
le mirage f 1 04 exemplaire doté de
toute l'électronique de bord prévu pour
la syrie d'école le 17 juin 1970
le premier vol de l'avion de série
numéro 1 a lieu à mérignac le 15 février
1973 aux mains de 10 me tomorrow art et
de 14 mars 1974 il sera livré à l'armée
de l'air
ce mirage f1 ouvrira la voie à plusieurs
versions
le croisement de route ici on va prendre
un cap 280 qui n'est pas une usine de
produits chimiques qui est une usine de
matériel léger
en 1993 les escadrons de combat un trait
artois et 2,13 auvergne faire de leurs
traditions pour récupérer leur nouvelle
identité à savoir 1 30 alsace et 2,30
normandie niemen tandis que le 3,13
disparaît
les deux escadrons de mirage f1 ct dont
la mission est la sau air-sol
conventionnelle font toute l'importance
de la base de colmar au sein des forces
aériennes de combat
l'un de ces deux escadrons et le
mythique régiment de chasse normandie
niemen au passé prestigieux et qui fête
cette année ses soixante deux ans
asson conventionnelle et police du ciel
sont les deux missions de base des
mirages f1 ct de la base aérienne 132
l'entraînement des pilotes se fait à
partir de la base même et consiste
principalement en des missions de
bombardement donc des missions d'assaut
et ce de jour comme de nuit vent
je n 259 de 5,9 au pied
le régiment de chasse normandie niemen
est constitué d'une vingtaine de pilotes
pour une quinzaine de mirage f1 ct dans
ses vingt pilotes on trouve environ 10
chef de patrouille ce qui constitue la
qualification maximale que l'on puisse
obtenir dans l'armée de l'air
on trouve également cinq sous chef de
patrouille à partir à un ou deux avions
au combat et environ cinq jeunes pilotes
capables d'assurer seules la mission
principale de l'unité à un seul avenir
les missions qui sont confiées à ces
deux escadrons se déroulant
principalement sur des théâtres
extérieurs
l'ensemble du personnel de la ba132 de
colmar travail à faire de cette base un
véritable outil de combat à la
disposition de l'état major prête à
faire face à toutes les actions dans
lesquelles elle pourrait être engagée
le fct est un chasseur bombardier
arrivée dans l'armée de l'air en 1992
d'une envergure de 8 m 44 pour une
longueur de 15 mètres 33 il présente une
masse à vide de huit mille 100 kg pour
une masse au décollage de 15 mille deux
cents kilos
le moteur snecma attar 9 4 56 l'équipe
d'une poussée de six mille huit cents
kilos lui permet d'atteindre la vitesse
de mach 2,1 à un plafond maxi de 16
mille cinq cents mètres
conçue au regard des enseignements tirés
du conflit iran irak le mirage f1 ct est
un chasseur polyvalent capable de
conduire des attaques air air et air sol
conventionnel dans la lignée des mirages
f1 le cul irakienne
le mirage f1 ct met en oeuvre une
panoplie d'armements presque identique à
celle du jaguar pour ce qui est de la
frappe air-sol avec des bombes guidées
laser principalement mais il a
l'obligation d'être accompagné d'un
avion marqueurs pour lui désigner sa
cible le laser
le mirage f1 c'était peut se voir
confier des missions d'accompagnement et
de protection en vol d'avions tels que
les awacs
obtenu par transformation de 55 cellule
de mirage f1 tirait ses 200 le mirage f1
ct est bel et bien avant toute chose un
chasseur bombardier son système d'armes
qui comprenait au début une centrale de
navigation inertielles sagem unis 47 tr
associés aux radars de bord cyrano 4 à a
bénéficié depuis l'an 2000 de
modernisation comme le recalage de la
centrale par gps ce qui est sûr
davantage de précisions à ce système
son poste de pilotage réaménagé comporte
aujourd'hui un calculateur talès m 182 x
air qui assure les fonctions de tir
air-sol ainsi qu un viseur tête au total
sbf 120
un télémètre laser monté sous le nez de
l'avion permet d'une part le tir
d'armement air-sol et d'autre part le
pointage très précis du canon embarquer
des uefa de 30 mm
doté d'une perche de ravitaillement en
vol et d'un réservoir pendulaires
centrale de deux mille deux cents litres
10 bidon irakien car développé pour les
mirage f1 eux qu irakien au début des
années 80 le f1 ct peut accomplir des
missions de longue durée
lors des ravitaillements en
configuration très chargé c'est à dire
avec quatre bombes et le fameux bidon
irakien le mirage f1 manque de puissance
et un manque de stabilité en lacets
malgré cela cette capacité a ravitaillé
en vol vaut entre autres à l'escadron de
combat 1,30 alsace d'armé en permanence
une patrouille d'intercepteurs dans le
cadre du plan de sûreté aérienne et de
participer au détachement épervier au
tchad
cheville ouvrière de l'escadron les
services techniques se doivent d'assurer
un degré de disponibilité élevé des
avions tout en garantissant la sécurité
des vols et du personnel des
spécialistes mécanicien motivés et
compétents oeuvre à ces tâches
techniques en tout temps en tout lieu et
ce quelles que soient les circonstances
extérieures ou encore les contraintes
mécaniques ou logistique
un peu plus d'une centaine de
mécaniciens électriciens et armuriers
entretiennent quotidiennement une
quinzaine d'appareils
l'escadron de chasse 1 prg en alsace
affiche une activité annuelle d'environ
4000 à 4200 heures de vol pour fixer les
idées une heure de vol nécessite une
activité de mise en oeuvre d' environ
3h30 suivi d'une activité de maintenance
d'environ 10 heures
malgré un nombre de rélever la cellule
du f1 ct qui est suivi en 1 10 de
fatigue affiche une intégrité mécanique
remarquable et il est prévu de conserver
les derniers appareils en service au
moins jusqu'à l'horizon 2013 2014
l'adaptation moteur cellule du mirage f1
a été particulièrement soignée pour
tirer le meilleur parti du réacteur
attar 9 qu'à 50 bien que
particulièrement fiable et facile
d'utilisation
ce moteur qui est le même que celui du
mirage iv reste toutefois d'une
conception ancienne monoflux monocorps
et régulations hydromécanique nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de son passé
au musée stigma de villaroche
snecma et son origine bien que
poursuivant la fabrication de moteurs à
pistons se doit de développer le moteur
d'avenir le turboréacteur
elle fait appel à un groupe d'ingénieurs
allemands transféré par les responsables
français 17 en 1945 à l' usine dornier
de récolte à sur les bords du lac de
constance
ce groupe est dirigé par le dr aux
pêcheurs qui a conçu et réalisé le bmw
0,03 de 800 kg de poussée construit
conserver à 450 exemplaires pour le
chasseur à 1160 de la raddho 234 et le
junkers 287
le docteur est riche et rejoint
185 spécialiste en grande partie six
anciens collaborateurs
l'unité ainsi constitué reçoit la
désignation d'ateliers aéronautique
aecon par donc les premières lettres
forment le side attaque
les octobre 1945
mais d'abord acteur de 1700 kg pouces et
pesant 850 kg et de température entre
tour 1652 ce moteur dénommé arcens le
v10 faire du bmw
003 pas un nouveau compresseur axial à
cet étage une régulation améliorer une
chambre de combustion a coûté une
nouvelle turbine un ensemble mobile
monté sur trois pales b au lieu de cap
une cuillère à et demi qui signifie
il est fabriqué par snecma l usine de
kellermann détournant ben aguida roche
pour la première fois le 26 mars 1948
entre temps le groupe strich guy groux
oddo a été transféré à decize dans la
nièvre pour jouer 1946 dans une usine de
la société dr othman fois sa filiale à
99 102 secma les pubs 1950 le premier
prototype atteint la poussée fixé de
1700 kg et le groupe o est intégré à
snecma la même année les cours
pourraient leur prototype sans enlever
et de près service en haïssant un b va
découler par améliorations successives
toute la famille des acteurs à part
avec la version 101 c de 2008 100 kg du
sein le compresseur et la chambre de
combustion sont modifiées et la vitesse
de rotation porté de 8,5 en talus 1400
tôt par minute d'un pouce et passe à
3000 kg pour le 100 1 des parts
augmentation du diamètre du compresseur
la tuyère devient vivant lettre
dans la version 100 en d3 la tuyère est
instruction aérodynamique la tare sens
mystère 2 est un des prototypes
prestigieux de décoller
dérivés du sang un thé la tare 101 peur
à compresseur à huit étages est
homologué en 1954 à 3500 puits à 3700 kg
de poussée ce moteur fabriqué à près de
600 exemplaires équipe l'avion de combat
pirateurs so4 1050 retour l'avion
d'appui tactique et en inde et le nord
1500 un griffon en combinaison avec un
statoréacteur en 1952 sur la
dénomination 101 m il permet à snecma
début juillet l'arrêt chose ou post
combustion
cette technique appliquée au 5 e tonne
le 101 g dont la série démarre en 1956
pour équiper le super mystère d2 et les
prototypes durandal et gère faux lequel
bas en 1957 le record du monde de monter
à 80
la phase de développement suivante des
bouchons les versions atteint 8 et atar
neuf avec réchauffe
le compresseur face à neuf étages et la
turbine à deux étages les poussées
respectives de ces trois acteurs sont de
4400 et 6000 kg
la tuyère de la table 9 c devient
multipolaire
l'étendard 4ème et la série des mirage
iii émirats chiens sont équipés de ces
moteurs fabriqués à plus de 2200
exemplaires
l'adaptation des étages transonic en
tête du compresseur à 9 étages permet un
nouveau bond en avant par augmentation
du débit
la tare neuf cas à une poussée de six
mille 700 kg
l'électronique entre en lice par un
correcteur de température d'entrée
turbines ceci donne en 1965 aux systèmes
d'armes mirage iv le meilleur rayon
d'action pour vol supersonique
la tarn jusqu'à 50 homologué en 1969 se
distingue principalement de la version
précédente par une nouvelle turbine une
régulation en température et vitesse à
correction automatique un dispositif de
protection du décrochage du compresseur
à aux incidences de laquelle il est mis
en service dès 1973 sur le mirage f1
après avoir effectué des essais en vol
sur le mirage milan et le mirage g8
biréacteur il permet à cet avion à
géométrie variable
d'atteindre la vitesse record de mac
2.34
ils équipent également la cellule du
mirage iii qui devient mirage 50
contrairement aux usages latin 8 k 5 ans
sans réchauffer à cuillères fixe
n'écoule d'un moteur avec réchauffe
existants qualifié en
1974 à une poussée de 5000 kg ils
équipent le super étendard de
l'aéronavale mise en service en 1978 ce
moteur dernier de la famille à part clos
cette saga en 50 ans plus de 5300 ata
ont été construits
équipant plus de 20 types d'avions dans
plus de 100 pays
les mirage f1 ct de colmar ont été
employées au feu avec succès durant le
conflit des balkans à partir de bases
italiennes et en collaboration avec les
jaguars de saint dizier
depuis le 11 septembre 2001 huit avions
en france assure une permanence 24
heures sur 24 ainsi par exemple deux
mirage f1 s'était basé à mont de marsan
reste en alerte permanente
leurs pilotes sont prêts à décoller en
deux sets où 15 minutes selon le degré
d'alerté fixé par le commandement de la
défense aérienne
depuis 1993 la base de reims accueille
le 1.3 belfort le 2 33 savoie sur mirage
f1 cr ainsi que le 3 33 lorraine et ses
mirages f1 b
l'activité de la base est largement
dominé par la mission de reconnaissance
des deux escadrons de mirage f1 cr
le mirage f1 cr est un des rares avions
encore en service qu'ils soient
spécialisés dans la reconnaissance
aérienne ces émissions sont le plus
souvent accompli par des avions de
combat équipé de nacelles spécifique sur
le f1 cr ses nacelles sont pour une
bonne part intégré à la cellule l'avion
emporte notamment une caméra panoramique
et un détecteur infrarouge sans oublier
les yeux du pilote spécialement formés à
ce type d'exercice
optimisé pour la reconnaissance le fsr
est aussi un avion de combat pouvant
tirer des armements classique ou à
guidage laser il possède un système de
navigation d'attaqué de reconnaissance
très élaboré ainsi qu'une centrale
inertielle hybride et gps lui permettant
d'être à la fois discret autonome et
précis dans ses navigations
l'avion conserve par ailleurs le radar
cyrano 4 du mirage f1 sait mais dans une
version modernisée surnommé
reconnaissance
le 3 33 lorraine est un escadron
d'entraînement dont le rôle est de
former les pilotes affectés sur f1 sait
où et facettés
l'escadron est aujourd'hui la dernière
unité de l'armée de l'air a utilisé les
f1 b dont elle dispose de dix
exemplaires complété depuis septembre
2003 par autant de f1 ct
le f1 b permet aux stagiaires
d'apprendre à piloter le f1 alors que le
f1 s'était quant à lui leur apprend à
utiliser un système d'armes complet au
cours de missions plus opérationnel
le pilote de reconnaissance doit être
curieux il doit prendre l'habitude de
regarder en dehors de son cockpit et ne
doit pas hésiter à faire du
renseignement en dehors de l'objectif
initialement prévu
à l'entraînement il n'est pas rare
qu'une mission de reconnaissance se
termine par une passe de tirs au canon
de 30 mm sur un champ d'exercice
histoire de ne pas oublier que nous
avons bien là un avion de combat
voix
l'ensemble des avions de ces trois
escadrons est remarquablement entretenue
par des équipes de mécaniciens assurant
une haute disponibilité des matériels
les officiers de renseignement sont
présents dans tous les escadrons mais
leur mission prend un relief tout à fait
particulier dans les escadrons de
reconnaissance au sein desquels
l'activité est concentrée
essentiellement sur le recueil et
l'exploitation de renseignement
si le travail des officiers de
renseignement consiste bien entendu à
informer le pilote qui part en mission
sur les menaces qui risquent de
rencontrer leur rôle principal est avant
tout d'aider le pilote a préparé sa
mission de renseignement et d'analysé à
ce retour les renseignements récoltés
ça c'est fini on a vu que 45 secondes
de retour de vol pilote officier de
renseignement et spécialistes photo
travaillent ensemble à l'identification
des clichy rapporté l'utilisation de
négatif de grandes dimensions et en noir
et blanc assure une excellente qualité
d'image
l'informatique prend toutefois de plus
en plus de place dans ce travail
d'analysé des informations
les capteurs disponible sur mirage f1 cr
comprennent des caméras embarquées à un
système de reconnaissance infrarouge un
radars à balayage latéral et plusieurs
nacelle dont la plus récente baptisé
presto permet de photographier
automatiquement à grande distance un
objectif désigné par ses seuls
coordonnées géographiques
bord
9e
à
le mirage f1 peut mettre en oeuvre une
grande variété d'armement de la bombe
lice à la bombe guidée laser
les bombes liste de 250 kg que l'on voit
ici sur un jaguar du17 provence sont des
bombes d'emploi général à largage en
semi piqué ou en vol horizontal et à une
hauteur de 500 m elles sont destinées à
faire face à la majorité des missions et
agissent par effets combinés de souffle
d'éclat est de mise
les gpu sont des bombes à guidage laser
leur masse varie selon les modèles
modèles sélectionnés en fonction de
l'objectif à détruire le mirage f1 peut
emporter jusqu'à quatre bombes
gbu-39 olemps bombe développé par la
société riffaud la gbu-12 d'une masse de
2 173 kg est une bombe à guidage final
destiné aux objectifs faiblement durci
la gbss d'une masse de 500 kg est
destiné à l'attaqué ouvrage durci de
moyenne importance
la gbuv 22 est une évolution de la
gbu-12 dont elles diffèrent notamment
par un guidage de troisième génération
ceci grâce à un kit laser pas vous et 3
les gpu 24 sont des bombes pouvant être
largué en paliers ressources la
puissance et la conception de leurs
charges militaires les destine à
l'atteinte d'objectifs durci
les gpu sont composés de deux parties à
savoir le corps et la charge active
partis qui sont assemblés soit dans la
soute à munitions soit au moment de la
mise en place soul elle
les diverses configurations sont testés
au cer centre d'expérimentation basé à
mont de marsan pendant que les pilotes
sont quant à eux accueillis par le ceta
centre d'études et d'instruction aux
tirs aériens situés sur la base de
cazaux
ces stages destinés aux futurs officiers
de tir en escadron permettent aux
stagiaires d'explorer l'inventaire des
munitions en service dans l'armée de
l'air en sillonnant tous les champs de
tir existants jusqu aux tyrans mais
roger rebat mme de lorient
en dehors de la formation traditionnelle
sur simulateur les pilotes reçoivent une
formation spécifique à l'église de reims
cette unité de formation fait partie de
la force aérienne de combat et est animé
par près de 75 personnes
elle est chargée de remplir deux
missions principales la mission
d'instruction spécialisés et la mission
d'animation technique
dans sa mission d'instruction
spécialisés les tice a assuré depuis
l'arrivée du mirage f1 dans les forces
la formation de plus de 15 mille
stagiaires elle assure encore
aujourd'hui la formation de près de 500
stagiaires par an pilotes et mécaniciens
français ou étrangers
dans sa mission d'animation technique
les tice à sur les traitements immédiat
est différée de l'ensemble des faits
techniques qui interviennent sur le
mirage f1 cette unité constitue le pôle
d expertise du mirage f1 pour la force
de combat
au sein de l'escadron 3,33 lorraine les
pilotes font l'objet d'une
transformation sous le contrôle de
moniteurs chevronnés ils deviendront
ainsi des prix à confirmer et apte à
rejoindre les f1 cr de race où les f1 ct
de colmar
à
pour la réalisation de ce film
différentes caméras ont été utilisés ici
la caméra équipée d'un tel objectif est
fixé sous la pointe avant d'un mirage
iii en poursuite sur la vie en essais
ce que l'on voit maintenant est obtenu
par une caméra placée dans la f1 à la
place du viseur et filmant vers l'avant
avec un objectif grand angulaire afin
d'obtenir à peu près le même champ de
vision que le pilote
ici le caméra est placée derrière le
siège est filmé une partie de la planche
de bord par l'intermédiaire de tunes
optique
la planche de bord a été modifié pour
regrouper dans la partie filmée la boule
le badin et l'altiste secours on voit à
gauche un incidence naître un ruban
différent de l'instrument de série avec
une zone rouge et une lampe au delà de
17 degrés
pour ce dernier type de séquence on a
utilisé une caméra au sol de très
grandes focale 12 100 mm montés sur un
affûts de canon mise en oeuvre par le ce
registre vous voyez ici l'avion vrillant
à 15 km de distance
et on peut distinguer en cherchant bien
un matra 530 sous la halle gauche
voici une courte perte de contrôle vue
sur la planche de bord arrière de f1 bis
place vous voyez le pilote a mis
fermement le manche en butée de
profondeur et gauchissement à droite
l'avion a déclenché le pilote lâche le
manche
est la leur prend pour débuter la
ressource
voici un exemple de break viol en
profondeur en buts et en virage à gauche
voyez il ne se passe rien
maintenant le pilote va mettre plein
manche à gauche pour provoquer le
déclencher
voilà qui est fait bel éventail vers la
droite et l'avion tourner en roulis est
lassé
recentrage les récupérations en tonneau
lent à droite ceci est un exemple de
déclencher tout à fait classique suivi
de un à deux tours de vrie
voici un autre exemple où le pilote
break en but est de profondeur bien
clonés soient tombés dans le trou le
pilote maintien manche de telle sorte
qu'ils ne se produit un des parents là
c'est assez rapide puis des agitations
parce qu'il insiste toujours
là le manche est lâché et les choses se
calment assez vite
voici un déclenché à 35 mille pieds 220
noeuds obtenu à la profondeur seul
l'avion a déclenché franchement et il
tourne puis le nez passe bas
et récupère dans certains cas le moteur
peut décrocher et s'éteint
le même et ses vues par le pilote
le départ
un tour recentrage
ça continue encore un bon tour puis du
tonneau à la fin
voici un essai avec volets de combat est
seulement de lm 38 qui ne sont pourtant
pas des charges importantes peut
déclencher est obtenue franchement
je ne dure pas très longtemps
l'avion passe tout de suite en agitation
et récupère assez bien
le pilote maintien plein dans chaque
gauche
l'avait en hausse il mais le déclencher
n'est pas obtenue
configuration 1 530 à droite beck combat
profondeur plein cabré l'avion par
d'abord à droite mais hésite ensuite le
pilote mais alors plaint manche à droite
donc côté en juin
ce qui va lancer une rotation rapide à
gauche
dès que le pilote se sentiraient vers
l'avant il lâche les commandes et vous
pouvez constater que la rotation
continue que la reprise de contrôle est
longue elle dure 16 secondes
même et s'est vu dans la cabine
voici le déclencher après un demi-tour
l'avion hésite longuement le nerf est au
le badin est très faible
à ce moment le pilote met pleinement ce
côté engins
et l'avion se met à tourner très
rapidement vers la gauche
le pilote subi près de 4 g vers l'avant
ce qui n'est vraiment pas très
confortable il lâche les commandes se
continue à tourner le nez restos les
agitations commence vous voyez le badin
toujours très faible tant que le néo
puis le nez passe-bas
le bada remonte le contrôle est enfin
repris
voici maintenant un exemple de
déclencher lancé à profondeur seul
voilà un bon départ
ici les commandes sont lâchés et vous
allez voir que la reprise de contrôle
demande pas mal de temps bien que les
mouvements ne soit pas très sévère
voici maintenant une série d'essais de
déclencher obtenu en croisant les
commandes vers 18 à 20 degrés
d'incidence dans des configurations
dissymétrique ici avec un magic à gauche
et beck combat les commandes étant lâché
au bout d'un tour vous voyez que l'avion
continue à s'agiter la rotation
s'inverse arrêt sur le dos et
récupération en roulis qui s'arrête tout
seul
mêmes conditions de départ 40 mille
pieds 250 noeuds de magic 1 530 à gauche
et aérofreins
ici le pilote croise les commandes à
fond
l'avion fait un éventail à droite
comment de lâcher vous voyez que dans la
récupération il ya inversion du sens du
roulis
même et ses vues par le pilote
voilà l'éventail à droite
le recentrage
l'euroligue qui s'inverse et l'avion qui
s'arrête en tonneau lent vers la gauche
on essaie vue du sol avec 1 530 à gauche
croisement des commandes et c'est parti
comment de lâcher la rotation continue
voyez c'est de la vrille
hélas les agitations survienne le nez
reste euros puis passe bas la
récupération commence
ici c'est récupérer vous pouvez
constater que l'ensemble a été plutôt
long
le même et ses vues par le pilote
quarante mille pieds 259
c'est parti
on lâche tout vous voyez ça continue à
tourner vite
le pilote est tiré vers l'avant
et voici maintenant la phase agitation
les inversions de sens du roulis des
grands mouvements de tangage
et enfin récupération
toujours le même et ses vues sur la
planche de bord
voilà le départ
la rotation en vrille
et voici la phase agitation regarder le
badin
voilà il commence à décoller du zéro
et progressivement il se met à monter
170 180 200 bleus
ici le contrôle est repris un super 530
à gauche et volets de combat voici le
déclencher et après un tour manches
pleines avant voyez ça tourne bien
voici un avion qui a déclenché à 40000
qui est 250 noeuds le pilote lâche les
commandes observé la dérive
voilà
l'avion est un rideau
dès le début le mirage f1 a connu des
succès à l'exportation
473 exemplaire équipe les armées de
l'air de l'afrique du sud de l'espagne
de la grèce du koweït de la libye de
l'équateur de l'irak de la jordanie du
qatar sans oublier ceux du maroc dont
nous voyons ici des f1 à l'entraînement
sur la base de mont-de-marsan
le mirage f 1 e e pour l'exportation
peut assurer toutes les missions du f1
sait mais avec de surcroît une
électronique permettant des missions air
sol plus précises et des distances de
tir plus grande
si depuis le 1er septembre 2003 le
mirage f1 c'est à quitter l'armée de
l'air les f1 ct et f1 cr poursuivent
quant à eux encore leur parcours quoi
qu'il en soit l'aventuré humaine du
mirage f1 dont 715 avions ont été
construits sous six versions différentes
restera à jamais gravé dans les mémoires
non